بالسفه التامه اجلاء الرعايه
السعوديين
والرعايه الدول الخليج بسفرائهم منذ ثلاثه
ايام وصلوا بحمد الله الى
المملكه وسلامه
ولكن هناك بعض السعوديين الذين يتواصلون
معنا ولم نكن على علم بهم وهم في عدد من
الولايات السودانيه ونتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمه في ترحيلهم منذ ان عرفنا
بمقرات تواجدهم وعديد منهم قادر امس
بالليل
واما عمليه الاجلاب بصفه عامه فهي مستمره
لكل
الرعايه الاجانب
الذين طلبت دولهم ان
تقوم المملكه بمساعدتهم بالاجلاء والوصول
الى مدينه جده حقيقه معظم الدول
غربيه وعربيه واسيويه
فمثلا
رجلين الرعايه امريكان بريطانيين
ايرانديين
وغيرهم ثم
وصلتهن رغبات من المغرب وتونس وموريتانيا
والجزائر والباكستان وتايلاند واليابان
وماليزيا وهذا
ورعاياهم البعض منهم وصل واجلناه والبعض
سيتم خلال هذه الليله
والايام القادمه اجلاهم بسلام ان شاء الله
الليله ان شاء الله ستغادر سفينه بحموله
2500 شخص